foreign
is going to start this hour off in
Dallas Texas hi William welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey Dave how you doing better than I
deserve man what's up
uh yeah I got a question about a prenup
um I've listened to a lot of your clips
uh some of them kind of Applied some of
them didn't but uh basically there's a I
own a business and have done well on
some properties
and there's a definitely a large gap
between me and my fiance what's your net
worth
uh net worth
um
property values are probably like 1.4 I
only have 230 in debt on those
um and then in cash I probably got like
750. what's your business worth
uh seven mil okay
so your 10 million dollar guy
and uh she has a more traditional normal
net worth she's not a freak like you
I guess not no you're a good freak
though I like you so it's good you're
the right kind of freak man I'm just
saying all right yes I would I would get
a prenup
okay okay I don't believe in prenups
I tell 99 of people not to get them the
only time in 30 years of coaching that
I've run into a situation where I wished
someone had had a prenup was where there
was a vast disparity
between the two people getting married
and 99 of the time the problem doesn't
end up being with the two people
it's not your fiance it's weird dadgum
people in her family
that come out of the woodwork and screw
up everything and if she can just hold
up the hand and go nope can't I gotta
prenup I don't have I got nothing to say
about that I got nothing because all of
a sudden they're like
little JoJo married William yeah let's
go visit you know I mean this is what
you know what I'm saying yeah I do yeah
and that's uh and and bless your heart
your fiance didn't see it coming because
she did not think crazy was going to
manifest itself that way in her extended
friends or family and so that and it
ends up screwing up y'all's relationship
the prenup actually assists the
relationship in this case so but for
everyone else I just say no if you have
to have a prenup to protect protect your
four dollars then you don't need to get
married
correct now what happens if you know
your fiance your girlfriend what does
she think about it
so that that's an issue
um you know she thinks that I you know
quote love my money more than her
um she's not thrilled or at least at the
beginning wasn't thrilled and so
um I basically you know because in Texas
you're you know everything is common you
know property once you get married and
so then it all gets split
um so I had pretty much what I had
structured was you know separating
everything and then maybe giving her
like
forever you were married if we were to
anything were to happen you know she
would get a certain amount per year you
know so I guess my next question would
be I would not do that
um and I would explain to her that this
is uh as much for her benefit it is as
yours because of what I just described a
few minutes ago
this gives her this releases her anyone
no one of your friends
are gonna be suspicious that she married
a gold digger none of your family is
going to think that she has bad motives
this helps her
mm-hmm and if you want to restructure or
do away with the prenup at any point in
your life you can do that
okay you can just go back into the
attorney the two of you sit down and go
you know what I'm going to release five
million dollars over here
well if you do a set thing on the number
of years the the year that that kicks in
or actually accidentally coincide to the
roughest year in your marriage
right and you will have that roughest
year you know that so I mean why
complicate it yeah true yeah and you can
go in and change it anytime but I don't
I I think I like her being Beyond
suspicion with all of your friends and
relatives for that matter her friends
and she also gets to hold up the hand to
her crazies that come along
and go look it's William's stuff but but
and then now having put the prenup in
place
that's the legal move then I would begin
to run the relationship as if you own it
all together
that's the key right there I think
that's the key that makes it all
all good so in other words if I were you
I'm going to talk to my wife before I
make a big business move
so that she's included this is not just
hey this is all my Mountain over here
you have no access you have you don't
get to you don't get to speak about this
yeah that's not what we're saying we're
saying if this if this whole thing hits
the wall you don't get any of this
that's all we're saying but that's
different then you don't get to speak
over it because she you want her to
speak over it proverbs 31 is who can
find a virtuous wife for her worth is
far above rubies the heart of her
husband safely trusts her and he will
have no lack of gain I have made more
money and built more wealth while
listening carefully to my wife who has a
home ec degree
and unbelievable hillbilly wisdom
now let's ask let me ask another
question on your behalf so your business
is worth seven million now the prenup is
only covering the current value let's
recover recover the ownership of the
business period period of what it
becomes oh that's crazy yeah that's the
way I would build it you can you can
wear it that way you don't have to put a
dollar amount on it that's interesting
though because if
they get married and now she's speaking
into the business the business is
growing and she still
she is completely I'll help you she's
completely benefiting if this business
is worth 14 million later instead of 7
million she's going to be eating right
that's right that is right she gets to
fly in that airplane but if something
happens
even the growth is no longer up for yeah
yeah but debate but again he can go back
and re-change that later he can and uh
if he looked up and said look the reason
this business went from 7 million to 25
million is uh she has really contributed
yeah then you can just remove some of
the prenup that is true
that is true I that's true
now I'm gonna run it as I'm gonna run
your relationship in your household and
all of your business decisions as if
she was there when it all began yeah and
this is my child bride wife that we got
married when we were whatever
children's I mean like Sharon I got
married at 22. we were like baby
children too yeah and so we were little
children's children so we got you know
we were both dumber than a rock and so
we grew the whole thing crashed it and
then grew another one together yeah
right so so there's no question about
that she owns it matter of fact she
technically owns most of it so but the
uh uh but the the the uh the point being
I'm gonna I'm gonna run the relationship
in a way that you don't Lord over her
assets or income she completely
participates in those and so we have an
income
from our business
unless we're divorced and then it's not
and then your boy gets it well that's it
I mean it's it it only turkey only comes
up if there's a problem right